La religión y la política van siempre de
la mano en la Península Arábica: la cuna
del Islam. Cada año, más de 2 millones de
peregrinos musulmanes viajan a Arabia Saudita
para visitar la Meca. En Abu Dhabi, convive
la arquitectura más moderna del planeta con
el apego por tradiciones milenarias. En esta
zona del mundo, el Islam es la ley. Sin embargo…
¿Y si te dijera que esta zona del mundo es
el lugar de mayor crecimiento del cristianismo?
Sí. Mientras Europa parece dar la espalda
a la Iglesia católica, es justo aquí, en
el epicentro del mundo islámico, donde más
está creciendo la población católica ¿Cómo
es eso posible? ¿Qué ha pasado en Abu Dhabi
para que incluso el Papa Francisco les haya
hecho una visita? ¿Estamos ante un cambio
histórico? En este vídeo te lo vamos a contar.
El Papa Francisco es algo así como el Leo
Messi de la religión. Da igual si eres o
no católico… o si eres o no del BARSA,
porque hagan lo que hagan, o digan lo que
digan, todo el mundo va a estar atento a sus
movimientos.
Además, tanto Messi como el Papa Francisco
tienen seguidores en los lugares más insospechados.
Porque, seamos honestos, tanto en Europa como
el Latino América, la Iglesia católica no
pasa por su mejor momento ¿Y que no sabéis
donde sí están creciendo en creyentes? ¡Exacto!
¡En la península arábica! Países como
Arabia Saudi, Qatar o Emiratos Árabes Unidos
tienen cada vez más y más católicos.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando… ¿Cómo
es esto posible? Por supuesto que tanto en
Qatar como en Emiratos Árabes Unidos es posible
construir iglesias. Pero echad un vistazo
a la catedral de Abu Dhabi…
¿A que no parece un templo católico? Lo
cierto es que es ilegal que muestren cruces.
En este país está terminantemente prohibido
predicar cualquier religión que no sea el
Islam. Y lo mismo pasa si eres musulmán y
te conviertes a otra fe: ¡Es un delito!
Como os podéis imaginar, este crecimiento
de la fé católica en Arabia se debe a una
única palabra: INMIGRACIÓN. Si seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo, ya sabéis que en esta
zona del mundo hay más inmigrantes que población
local. En Qatar o en Emiratos Árabes Unidos,
hablamos de más del 80% de la población.
Por supuesto que muchos de estos inmigrantes
son musulmanes: gente que viene de países
como Bangladesh o Pakistán. Pero también
hay Estadounidenses, colombianos o filipinos
que son católicos. Y eso explica cosas como
esta.
Visita papal: el Papa Francisco aterriza en
Abu Dhabi para su histórico primer viaje
al Golfo
Habéis oído bien. Por primera vez en la
Historia el Papa de la Iglesia Católica ha
visitado la Península Arábiga. Y su viaje
ha sido como una JMJ en miniatura: 180.000
personas acudieron a su misa en Abu Dhabi.
Más del doble de asistentes que en la última
misa que dio en un país tan católico como
Chile. En otras palabras… ¡SM DANI, traduce
tu canal al árabe, que ahí tienes mercado!
Y os preguntaréis, ¿Por qué han permitido
este éxito católico en un país musulmán?
Es más, ¿Por qué ha ido el Papa a Abu Dhabi?
¿Qué puede conseguir? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
FACTA NON VERBA
El Papa Francisco y Messi tienen muchas cosas
en común. Ambos son los capitanes de sus
organizaciones. Aunque, en realidad, Francisco
es el líder de 3 organizaciones a la vez.
Habéis oído bien.
Por un lado, el Papa es la cabeza de la jerarquía
eclesiástica. Esa es su parte religiosa donde
no vamos a entrar porque esto es un canal
de política.
Lo cierto es que su santidad el papa también
tiene un rol político. Por un lado, es el
jefe de estado de un estado soberano: la Ciudad
del Vaticano. El estado más pequeño del
mundo. Pero, además, también es el jefe
de la Santa Sede. Y, creedme, Ciudad del Vaticano
puede ser el país más pequeño del mundo
pero… la influencia diplomática de la Santa
Sede es infinita. Tienen embajadas en prácticamente
todos los países del mundo. Y han jugado
un rol fundamental en la historia.
Por ejemplo, el Papa Juan Pablo II fue una
pieza fundamental para la caída del comunismo,
tanto en Polonia como en toda la Unión Soviética.
Y fue una de las principales voces en contra
de la Guerra de Irak.
Su sucesor, Benedicto XVI, fue algo menos
político. Su legado se mide más por sus
ensayos y sus encíclicas que por su trabajo
diplomático.
Pero el actual pontífice es todo lo contrario.
Tal vez uno de los papas más políticos de
todos. Y por eso genera tantas opiniones.
Para unos es un malvado comunista y para otros
es el gran renovador y el adalid de la justicia
social. Un hombre al que no le tiembla el
pulso para decir esto del capitalismo.
El Papa Francisco sobre la desigualdad económica:
“Una economía así mata”
Desde luego, Jesucristo podría hablar en
parábolas pero al Papa Francisco no le gusta
andarse con rodeos.
El Papa: Donald Trump “no es cristiano”
si quiere construir un muro fronterizo
Pero si nos vamos a los hechos, descubrimos
un papa muy distinto. Si Donald Trump decía
eso de “los americanos primero” la política
de Francisco podría resumirme también como
“los católicos primero”.
Y ya sé que esto puede sonar un poco prosáico.
Pero vamos a ver la Iglesia como si fuera
una multinacional. Bajo este prisma, el catolicismo
está cayendo en sus mercados tradicionales.
En número de creyentes en Europa se derrumba,
mientras en América afronta una feroz competencia
con las iglesias evangélicas. Así que en
el Vaticano lo han tenido claro: hay que buscar
nuevos mercados.
Los que seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo
posiblemente recordaréis el video que dedicamos
al acercamiento de la Iglesia católica con
el régimen comunista de China.
Os hago un resumen rápido por si no habéis
visto el vídeo. El catolicismo estaba prohibido
en China. Y como los chinos son muy listos,
se habían inventado una Iglesia católica
Made in China, muy parecida a la del Vaticano
pero donde los obispos los nombra el Partido
Comunista.
Los católicos que se mantenían fieles al
Papa de Roma eran enviados a campos de concentración
donde se les torturaba y se les sacaban los
órganos para los trasplantes. Ante esta situación,
probablemente Juan Pablo II habría optado
por un perfil más combativo. Pero Francisco
es mejor negociante que el propio Donald Trump.
Y ahí es donde entra el sistema de trasplante
de órganos chino. Durante años, China ha
estado extirpando órganos de presos políticos
para su sistema de donantes. Hay toda clase
de presiones internacionales para que acaben
con este sistema, que viola los derechos humanos.
China, mientras tanto, lo niega todo aunque
todas las pruebas digan lo contrario.
Pues bien, el Vaticano fue el primer y único
estado del mundo hasta la fecha que invitó
a los diplomáticos chinos para que pudieran
vender las bondades de su sistema
de trasplantes. En otras palabras, que el
Papa Francisco dio carta de naturaleza a los
trasplantes de órganos chinos.
¿Qué consiguió por eso? Pues… esto.
China y el Vaticano llegan a un acuerdo sobre
el nombramiento de los obispos
Fácil y sencillo. Bastó con una negociación
diplomática y ¡Boom! La Iglesia Católica
acaba de sumar 12 millones de feligreses nuevos.
Sólo con esto ya han compensado la pérdida
de creyentes en España durante los últimos
30 años.
¿Así que cuál ha sido la siguiente parada
del Papamóvil? ¡Exacto! ¡El mundo árabe!
Mientras Benedicto XVI criticaba abiertamente
el Islam, Francisco ha dado un giro de 180º
en este tema. Por ejemplo ¿Os acordáis de
los atentados de Charlie Hebdo? Casi todos
los líderes mundiales condenaron los ataques
y el terrorismo religioso. Sin embargo, en
este caso, el Papa Francisco sí que optó
por las parábolas.
"No se puede insultar la fe de los demás
(…) Si el doctor Gasbarri dice una mala
palabra en contra de mi mamá, puede esperarse
un puñetazo... ¡Es normal!"
¡Pero los gestos de amor hacia el Islam no
se quedan aquí! Por ejemplo…
…aquí tenemos al Papa Francisco y el gran
imán de Al Azhar, máximo representante de
los musulmanes suníes, juntos hicieron un
llamamiento a construir un mundo más tolerante
y menos violento.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Para qué sirve este
acercamiento? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver.
ESCLAVISTAS PERO TOLERANTES
Otra cosa que tienen en común Messi y el
Papa Francisco es su familia. Como buenos
argentinos, ambos son descendientes de inmigrantes
italianos. Y donde también hay muchos inmigrantes
es… en la península arábiga.
Pero bueno, como en todo, siempre hay clases.
Hay que distinguir entre los expats y los
inmigrantes. El expat es un europeo o estadounidense
que se va a trabajar un par de años a Exxon
Mobile cobrando una auténtica pasta. El inmigrante
es el asiático que comparte habitación con
otros 10 trabajadores, trabaja 12 horas al
día y cobra un salario ridículo. La mayor
parte de estos inmigrantes trabaja en la construcción
o como empleada del hogar. Mantienen a sus
familias, que viven a miles de kilómetros
de distancia.
Y diréis “bueno, pero si no les gustan
las condiciones, siempre pueden volverse a
su país” ¿Verdad? Pues… no es tan fácil.
Veréis, en Arabia impera el llamado sistema
KAFALA. Según la KAFALA, los inmigrantes
están ligados a un local que es su patrocinador.
Si quieren cambiar de trabajo, de empresa
o marcharse del país, necesitan el permiso
de este patrocinador. Si el patrocinador no
les da ese permiso, están condenados a seguir
trabajando durante años en condición de
esclavitud.
Pues bien, sólo en Emiratos Árabes Unidos
hay más de un millón de católicos que viven
bajo este sistema. Inmigrantes que vienen
de Filipinas o de algunas partes de la India.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, en semejante
situación, uno se aferra a la religión más
que a otra cosa.
Por otra parte, aunque estén en condición
de esclavitud, todos estos trabajadores son
fundamentales para la economía ¿Quién construiría
si no? En otras palabras, que construir una
catedral en Abu Dhabi es la forma más barata
de tener moderadamente contentos a los que
sustentan tu economía.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cómo es posible
que en un sitio donde está prohibido hacer
proselitismo de otras religiones, se pueda
construir una catedral? Pues, mis queridos
amigos de VisualPolitik: el enemigo de las
monarquías árabes no son ni los cristianos
ni los hindúes… son otros musulmanes ¿Por
ejemplo? Los hermanos musulmanes.
Pensadlo bien ¿Qué es más peligroso para
los jeques? ¿Los inmigrantes filipinos rezando
en una iglesia o los Hermanos Musulmanes,
que no aceptan otra autoridad que el Corán?
Está claro, ¿no? Por eso en Emiratos Árabes
Unidos tienen cosas mejores que hacer que
dedicarse a perseguir cristianos. Y eso explica
tantísima tolerancia… a cambio de poder
violar los derechos humanos sistemáticamente.
EL PAPA EN ABU DHABI
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando: vale, puede
que en Abu Dhabi permitan que se construya
una iglesia pero… ¿Una visita del Papa?
¿Para qué?
Pues lo cierto es que les viene genial. Por
un lado, mejoran su imagen al exterior. De
repente, ese país que era famoso por el fanatismo
islámico… ¡Acoge al líder de otra religión!
A ver quién es el guapo que se atreve a poner
en duda la modernización en el mundo árabe
ahora ¡Pero no sólo eso! Con apenas esfuerzo,
Abu Dhabi le acaba de dar una alegría enorme
a su población católica. La visita es una
buena noticia tanto para los filipinos que
trabajan por cuatro petrodólares como para
los europeos con megasueldazos de las multinacionales.
Pero la pregunta… la auténtica pregunta
es… Qué gana entonces la Iglesia Católica?
Pues pensadlo bien… el Papa ha llegado a
una zona del planeta donde estaba prohibida
la evangelización y ha conseguido que le
dejen organizar la madre de todas las misas.
Una misa en el principal estadio de futbol
del país, con 180.000 personas y esta pedazo
cruz que se podía ver desde el último minarete
de Abu Dhabi.
A esto se le llama poner una pica en Flandes.
Y todo eso explica que el vicario apostólico
de Arabia, Paul Hinder, diga estas cosas tan
bonitas del gobierno de Emiratos Árabes.
Rezad por los gobernantes de este país que
hacen posible la visita. Agradezco al gobierno
de los Emiratos Árabes Unidos por su generosidad,
no solo han hecho posible la visita sino que
nos han brindado de todo corazón un lugar
para celebrar la misa.
¿Y qué me decís del Papa Francisco? Con
Donald Trump no tiene pelos en la lengua.
Sin embargo, durante toda su visita no ha
dicho una palabra ni del sistema KAFALA ni
mucho menos de la guerra de Yemen.
Vuestro país, tierra que quiere ser un modelo
de convivencia, de fraternidad humana y de
encuentro entre diferentes civilizaciones
y culturas
Después de estos gestos, no sería raro si
Emiratos Árabes Unidos terminara quitando
las restricciones religiosas. Al menos, las
que afectan al catolicismo. Esto supondría
un espaldarazo tremendo para la Iglesia Católica
en un mercado aún por explorar.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que el Papa es un genio de la negociación?
¿O tal vez debería preocuparse un poco por
los derechos humanos? ¿Podríamos decir que
se merece el balón de oro a la diplomacia?
A fin de cuentas, es Cristiano y siempre viste
de blanco (guiño, guiño…).
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, si queréis ampliar vuestra perspectiva,
os dejo este otro vídeo que ha hecho SM DANI
en su canal hablando sobre el mismo tema.
SM DANI es el sacerdote más famoso de todo
YouTube y tiene perspectivas y entrevistas
muy interesantes. Aquí podréis ver una visión
de la política papal desde el punto de vista
de un creyente que conoce la Iglesia como
la palma de su mano.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas. Así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!